the Star Wars prequel trilogy gave fans
of the popular sci-fi franchise many
things a look at Anakin Skywalker's
growing up and an explanation of how he
became a Sith Lord a peek behind the
curtain at the politics fueling the
Empire a huge pet peeve in the form of
Jar Jar Binks and even a young Boba Fett
the notorious bounty hunter from the
original trilogy Boba Fett made his
first appearance chronologically
speaking anyway and Star Wars Attack of
the Clones the second installment in the
prequel trilogy he also appeared as a
youngster on the animated series Star
Wars the Clone Wars which gave us the
story of how boba fett began on the path
to becoming the galaxy's fiercest and
most fearsome bounty hunter
you may take Captain solo at the time of
Attack of the Clones the character was
only ten years old and living on the
planet Kamino with his father bounty
hunter Jango Fett of whom he was
actually a clone child actor Daniel
Logan portrayed young Boba Fett's on the
big screen but what happened to him what
does the kid who played the most famous
bounty hunter in the Star Wars universe
been up to in the years since he came
back down to earth for starters the Star
Wars prequels didn't put Logan off from
acting like they did with young Anakin
Skywalker actor Jake Lloyd rest assured
that this 32 year old New Zealand er is
still in the biz to this day after
appearing an attack of the clones in
2002 Logan made a number of more low-key
appearances in films and on television
in 2003 he led his voice to the animated
series - Kapoor a Gannett in the South
Seas and the feature film The Legend of
Johnny lingo he was even the voice
behind the animated incarnation of Boba
Fett for five episodes of the Clone Wars
which ran for five seasons on Cartoon
Network beginning in 2008 a sixth was
produced for Netflix and a seventh will
released on Disney Plus more recently
Logan has held roles in sharknado for
the forth awakens playing a character
named wait for it captain Fett he also
appeared in the griddle house and
underdogs rising he's set to appear in
the theatrical feature at the time war
and the TV movie The Oath outbreak both
of which are currently in
post-production when the Star Wars
sequel trilogy was announced there was
also talk of a Boba Fett spin-off film
and at that time photos surfaced of
Logan being kitted out in a
Boba Fett costume the actor is active on
social media with plenty of photos on
Instagram to show he still has young
Boba's cheeky side grin and he's also
shared a number of images of himself
trying on a full costume or bits and
pieces thereof of course there's no
doubt it was a costume he commissioned
for himself as there's no way a company
like Disney would stand for him sharing
photos of an official costume for a film
before the studio had released its own
photos and trailers nothing was ever
confirmed with regards to a possible
role for Logan in the Boba Fett film but
it certainly wouldn't have been outside
the realm of possibility for him to make
it return to the Star Wars universe it's
quite clear that the actor would have
been more than happy to make a big
comeback in the franchise at the chance
of risen unfortunately the film was
canceled late in 2018 after solo a Star
Wars story underperformed at the box
office
Logan still makes as many public
appearances as he can with other Star
Wars franchise stars he attends the
Comic Cons of the world where he poses
for photos with fans and thanks them for
the continued support
although he certainly isn't among
Hollywood's a-list after the promising
early start to his career Logan is still
in the industry and reliving his boba
days as often as he can the actor is
also married and has an adorable little
clone of his own his young son Brad who
just might follow in his father's
footsteps sound like someone else we
know check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite films are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]